[Music]
J so lovely to be here with you today
thank you so much thank you so let's
start at the beginning tell me about how
you founded your company sure so maybe
I'll just talk a little bit about kind
of my personal story and and why I care
about this topic so much um so for just
as an overview uh we have we provide
tools and curriculum to teach computer
science and AI to middle school and high
school students so we try to empower
teachers to teach the subjects students
to learn the subjects um and so I took
uh computer science for the first time
as a freshman in college and it was
super super difficult for me um I always
felt like I had to work like twice as
hard as other people my friends many of
my friends also felt the same way um and
this kind of affected our self-esteem
for years afterwards right because I
think you know the way that you're
taught and your education can have a
huge impact on self-esteem and your
sense of self-worth and how you see
yourself so that experience kind of
shaped how I thought um education can
impact your self-esteem um and then you
know I continued to take computer
science I graduated with a degree in in
computer science and machine learning I
worked at Nasa for a few years on the
March 2020 Rover then I went to business
school at Stanford and that's actually
where um or that's actually how I met my
co-founder and CEO of cir learning um
Andrea pasinetti and so he also
graduated from Stanford a few years
before I did and honestly he he kind of
just sent an email out to the current
students and he was like he so he was
working with our current chairman um
Andrew Ang and they were kind of toying
with this idea of of just Computer
Science Education was becoming a huge
need in the country and the world they
weren't exactly sure what they wanted to
do with it but they knew that it was a
huge need so I actually um interned with
uh my my co-founder and CEO Andrea that
summer and then we and then I worked
part-time my second year business school
and then I started working full-time so
that's kind of how the journey started I
guess very cool so what was the biggest
thing that you wanted to change about
Computer Science Education and how did
you do that oh man yeah that's a that's
a really really good question um so from
my personal experience and from what I
saw I think uh many intro classes in
computer science and AI are very very
difficult like the intro class that I
took as a freshman in college I do not
think it was an intro class right it was
they they said it was for people who had
never taken CS or never coded before I I
mean it was it was not right and that
again huge impact on self-esteem so I
think one of the main things is that we
want to make um computer science and Ai
and these subjects are becoming so
important to learn right about just how
the world works so we want to make those
those intro classes in particular
accessible and motivating and something
that kind of builds self-esteem and it
you know I I truly believe these
subjects are something that anybody can
learn and and everybody should have a
fundamental understanding of how they
work because it's a huge part of how our
world works these days I mean it's hard
to name a product that doesn't use
computer science in some way um right so
I think just making it um motivating and
and kind of building self-esteem is is
is very very huge and of course also um
talking a lot about the applications so
there's so that's actually one thing
that Drew me to the subject um because I
really liked you know going into college
I really liked chemistry and and biology
and all of that and and then I realized
there are lots of applications of
computer science in those areas and I
can potentially help people that way too
so we talk a lot about the applications
piece too very cool yeah what made you
think that you could or should take the
dive into entrepreneurship instead of a
more traditional path yeah that's a good
question so um I guess maybe I'll I'll
talk a little bit about why I decided to
go to business school because that was a
huge pivot right I went to um celtech a
pretty small engineering school and then
I worked at the jet propulsion lab um
one of the NASA centers and so it was it
was a very different kind of environment
but I think what what propelled me to
think a lot more about education as a
career was because uh JPL is a pretty
good education outreach program so I
started to teach at schools and and
libraries in my free time um and then
again actually through that experience
um as well as I also well so I also
tutored kids living in in mostly like
women's shelters too um and that
experience all these experiences kind of
showed me again the impact of education
and the way that somebody's taught on
their self-esteem and just how it makes
them feel um so I just that was what was
motivating to me um you know after like
three years of working at JPL I learned
so much but that I I just wanted to see
if I could turn this this passion of
mine into a career um so then I knew
that Stanford in particular they have
some pretty good education classes and
and I had done quite a bit of research
on some of the education companies that
came out of it so I mean to be complet
completely honest I went into business
school being pretty open right I didn't
really know anybody that even worked at
a startup or so I I had a lot to learn
so I kind of went into it with the
attitude like I want to see if I can
work in education somehow and help
people believe in themselves through the
way that they're taught that was like
kind of my high Lev thing um and then I
just started talking to a lot of people
at startups and learning a little bit
more about it um and then when Andrea
reached out my co-founder I think a
conversation with him um several
conversations with him and my experience
interning with him over the summer is
really what motivated me because I saw
like he's also just a really good human
being and I respect him a lot of course
as you know a CEO and my co-founder but
also just as a person so I think
personally that's really important who
you surround yourself with like it
should be somebody that you know I I
really respect and I think is a good
human being and all of that so and he
was a great mentor as well so that was a
huge and actually I will say I think he
made me believe that I could do it and
be a co-founder um much more than I did
so yeah I think that was a very honest
answer yeah now your Target customers or
you're selling it to school districts
correct yeah yeah how do you convince
them to to take a chance on you in this
new technology yeah yeah so um yeah
currently we like our biggest
partnership is is a partnership with the
state of Tennessee um so how that worked
actually is we went through an RFP
process with the state so Tennessee I
mean really realizes the value of
Computer Science Education right I mean
I think like I said it's informing so
much about how the world works these
days so they they want their students to
to learn about this subject and and and
for those who who end up liking it and
want to pursue a career in it they want
to give them the opportunity um so we
actually like we actually work with the
state like that that was kind of how we
originally got this contract and so
pretty much the state chose us as their
provider for computer science education
so they're actually going to have a
graduation requirements starting next
fall which requires every single high
school student in the state of Tennessee
to have to take computer science to
graduate which is like that's huge right
more and more states are starting to do
this and Tennessee is kind of at the
Forefront of it so we are their chosen
provider for this this curriculum
awesome how many states and schools are
you in right now yeah let me think um so
so Tennessee is we have that whole state
partnership with we're also we've
actually um so the state of Ohio has
actually us used one of our our courses
as as well one of our many AI courses
too um we're speaking to New York
California um we've spoken to Arkansas
as well as other countries too so East
and West Africa as well as in Asia so
there's there's a lot that's amazing
yeah talk to me about your fundraising
Journey what's that been like and how
much have you raised yeah yeah so um our
most recent round uh we raised our most
recent rounds was our series a and it
was led by Nea new Enterprise Associates
um so it's 15 million um and I think so
far we've raised about 21 million
excellent yeah can you talk to me a bit
about um any metrics to show the scale
of your company can you talk about how
you've had sales growth or Revenue
growth or user growth yeah yeah so I
would say we've had about um 2.5 to
three million in sales I would I will
say I want to check that um with the
numbers just to make sure I'm still like
on track and and because we've gotten
some recent contracts as well um so yeah
I think this the partnership with
Tennessee has been a big one right so
that's that's a big contract that we've
had um and then we're continuing to kind
of add States as we go very cool what's
been the most challenging part of
running a company oh man let me think
about that one well I think so for me
personally I have hadn't even worked at
a startup before much less help run one
um so I think there's a lot of um
shifting priorities that have to happen
all the time we give a lot of importance
to the feedback from from our users
which are teachers and students
ultimately so we try to visit like I was
in Tennessee two weeks ago I visited
several times we're going to visit soon
again um right and I think it's this
this balance between like we are we are
create specifically maybe I'll sorry
maybe I'll talk about a challenge
between of creating this kind of company
in particular where computer science and
AI education is so new and it hasn't I
mean there aren't there aren't many
other players in the space right now
especially those that work directly with
kind of states and schools right so I
think one challenge is that um a lot of
these teachers are they're teaching the
subject for the first time which is like
if you can imagine you know like going
into a classroom teaching a subject for
the first time that your students are
also learning for the first time hard
that's hard and that's like to we we saw
some of these teachers teach with our
curriculum in classrooms and it was like
it was inspiring right like they cared
so much about this and I think so so you
know sometimes they might not exactly
know what is needed but they know their
pain points like they know what's not
working and everything and so we have to
figure out like how do we solve this
issue that hasn't really been solved
before um so I think um that was kind of
a long answer to your question but I
would just say figuring out what is most
important to prioritize in the moment
and then there's always this balance
between right we want to improve our
product or platform and our curriculum
in the long term and then we also want
to address the issues that are current
users are facing like as fast as
possible and there's a trade-off between
that right so both of those take time
totally who are your biggest competitors
in the space and how do you set yourself
apart yeah that's a good question so I
would say we have two main competitors
at least like what we're hearing from
schools and classrooms um codehs as well
as uh code.org so I would say there's a
couple ways that we set ourselves apart
um one is that we have a big focus on AI
education so I I studied AI like in
undergrad I worked in the AI group at
Nasa for the Mars 2020 perseverance
Rover and and our our like Andrea has
experienced in AI our chairman Andrew
Ang is he's done a lot of um work in AI
education more for adults so far so we
and then we're also working with several
um people from Stanford like researchers
and professors and Berkeley who have
experience teaching this subject so
we're able to build curriculum like AI
based curriculum um for students right
and that's I mean that's not an easy
thing to do especially to build that
kind of curriculum that is accessible
and motivating for younger students so
that's one piece another piece is we
also have video instruction our courses
are actually designed such that they can
be taken completely asynchronously if
you want which means we need to make
them really really bite-sized and
accessible to everyone so there is like
onetoone video instruction that goes
along with activities and exercises and
projects as well and then we have a huge
focus on applications too but I mean um
those are those are just a couple of the
ways we differentiate now ai obviously a
big area of focus as we just brought up
it's such a buzzard right now and I
think everyone's talking about how to
regulate it the ethics around it how are
you looking at that as you're educating
kind of the Next Generation to come in
use it responsibly yeah yeah no that's a
huge Focus actually um so I'll I'll talk
a little bit about one of our AI courses
that's going to come out soon so the
first thing that we actually talk about
in that course is about language models
and this is designed for you know this
course is going to be designed for 10th
graders who who've never who don't have
ai experience at all before and we just
get into it talking about language
models and some of the applications of
that and there's a lot of ethical kind
of concerns and issues that need to be
thought about so we actually give them
again this is from unit one we give them
a framework to think about AI
applications that account for the
potential consequences both good and
potentially bad so from the get-go like
when they start learning about it we try
to train them to think about these
applications so that they it will almost
become a habit that they have to think
about kind of what data these
applications are using how they're being
trained so that they're they're being
built responsibly and ethically yeah
very interesting yeah so would you ever
sell your company and if so what would
it take to have that happen oh man um I
feel like I would need to think a little
bit more about this one I mean I think
my immediate answer is would I ever I
mean yes like you know I I don't think
about that right now like I think we're
um we're able to make a lot of impact um
with what we're doing right now and what
would it take to happen um I
think potentially if there's a good if
maybe we see that we could potentially
make a lot more impact good impact by
selling the company um then that I think
that that could happen but it's honestly
it's not something that we think about
right now yeah yeah that's that's okay
you're still
young um and speaking of that you know
what's it it like to be a young woman in
a very male Centric Tech field
especially a young woman too yeah yeah
um so you know it's interesting when I
was working in the AI group before I at
at JPL I was yeah I was one of like a
few women out of like a group of about
30 and it was it was it was tough um but
I also think it's so important to have
mentors and people who who support you
like I I I definitely still have a lot
to learn and especially beginning when I
started the company I was like I this is
just I just knew it was something I
really care about but exactly how to go
about it in a business sense I was I had
a lot to learn so um I think I've been
really grateful that I get a lot of
support from my co-founder and my team
members who are awesome like I think we
encourage each other and everything and
and also you know it's really it's
really endearing and motivating for me
to see when we visit uh schools in
Tennessee right like I get to talk to
the girls taking those classes and they
come up to me and like we chat and I
think it's that is kind of what what
motivates me keep keeps me going but I
will say right now at Kira like I
haven't I haven't faced you know issues
in that sense because my all all my team
members are really incredible that's
great yeah is there one piece of
business advice or a rule that you
always operate by no matter what yeah
there is and uh I don't know if this
counts as business advice but it's it's
going to sound simple but it's really to
treat people well and with respect um
and empathy and I think like whether
it's business or personal I I I truly
believe this and maybe I'm I'm
privileged to have experienced this and
believe this I think if you treat people
well treat them with respect and empathy
then the right people will surround you
and the right people will support you um
and that's that's actually I I feel like
we talk about that in our courses too
because I think Ed one big role
education has is you know I mean kids
are learning these different subjects in
a very important time in their life so
it's important to to show them that like
kindness and empathy can go a long way
too so that's and I I think it it can go
a long way in business you know
professional personal so that's tot
agree it can be really apped to anything
yeah it sounds simple but I think it's
it's really really important to remember
on a day-to-day basis so what's next for
you what's next for Kira any exciting
things down the pipeline in 2024 yes so
I'll talk about something we're actually
currently working on that I'm personally
super excited about um so we often get
the question Okay so you teach AI or do
you use AI to improve learning and
teaching and the answer is both right so
I've talked a little bit about how we
teach Ai and computer science and our
approach to that um so one thing we're
working on now is actually using Ai and
language models to improve the learning
and teaching um experience so yeah I
would love to talk a little bit about
that so please one really common feeling
in computer science is this feeling of
of just being really really stuck like
you you're writing a computer program
and you run into an issue an error and
then you just you don't know how to
solve it and you know actually my my
co-founder Andrea put this really well
once he's pretty much like computer
science a very is a very unique subject
because you're constantly interacting
with a computer and there's a lot of
feelings involved but the computer
doesn't care right like it's it's and
that's that's tough so I think this
feeling of just being stuck and not
knowing when you'll be unstuck is very
common so what we're doing is we're
developing this AI I like to call it
learning companion we're still figuring
out the name but essentially as a
student is taking a course or a project
project um they they can use this AI
tutor learning companion which will give
them guidance so that they can become
unstuck so it will just give them enough
guidance so that they can move on to the
next step but not give them the answer
so that's something we're we we're
really really working on how do we make
sure that these this you know AI product
does not give the answer not only the
wrong answer because that would be
horrible and that can happen right but
um but so it certainly cannot give the
wrong answer but even an answer at all
right we still want the students to
learn but we don't want this feeling of
being stuck forever to prevent them from
making progress that's a great I like
the Micosoft paper clip on the side too
yeah yeah so I think yeah so I think
that is we're I mean we're we're going
to release it pretty soon a beta version
pretty soon um and I think that has a
potential for a lot of impact especially
because the teachers are often teaching
this for the first time too right so I
think they can also use yeah they you
know if a student ask them a question
and they don't need the answer they can
also use this tool to not only improve
their learning improve their teaching
very cool I'll look forward to that for
sure yeah that's a huge one and last
question for you what would you like
your legacy to be what would I like my
legacy to be um I think this maybe ties
back to the piece of advice it's going
to sound simple but um I guess I hope I
can be somebody that helps other people
believe in themselves a little bit more
I think education has a big role to play
in that um so I think if we can create a
product and courses and curriculum that
make people feel like they have the
potential to be who they want and do
what they want that'll be great um that
and I just hope I can be someone that's
empathetic and kind and can help others
do the same that's amazing well thank
you so much I appreciate your advice and
you're being here and sharing your story
thank you so much Kristen it was great
talking